Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Ir de prácticas a un laboratorio
en plena montaña
a lo mejor no fue la mejor idea.
Tirar de la palanca marcada
con el símbolo de una calavera
solo para ver qué pasa, probablemente
tampoco fue muy inteligente,
pero ahora no es el momento
para lamentarse
porque hay que alejarse rápidamente
de estos zombis mutantes.
Te acompañan el portero, la asistente
de laboratorio y el viejo profesor.
De momento juegas con ventaja, pero
hay solo un camino hacia la salvación:
a través de un viejo puente de cuerda
por encima de un desfiladero inmenso.
Puedes estar en el otro lado en un minuto,
mientras que a la asistente de
laboratorio le hacen falta dos minutos.
El portero es un poco más lento
y necesita cinco minutos,
y el profesor necesita
un total de 10 minutos
para aferrarse a las cuerdas
a cada paso en el camino.
Según los cálculos del profesor,
los zombis los alcanzarán
en poco más de 17 minutos,
por lo que tienen solo este tiempo para
llegar al otro lado y cortar las cuerdas.
Por desgracia, el puente solo puede
sostener a dos personas a la vez.
Para empeorar las cosas,
está tan oscuro que apenas se ve,
y la vieja linterna que tomaron para el
camino, solo ilumina un área pequeña.
¿Puedes encontrar la manera que
le permita a todos escapar a tiempo?
Recuerda: no más de dos personas
pueden cruzar el puente a la vez,
y cualquiera que cruza debe sostener
la linterna o permanecer a su lado
mientras que uno puede
esperar y estar seguro
en la oscuridad de cada
lado del desfiladero.
Lo más importante, todos
deben cruzar al otro lado
antes de que lleguen los zombis.
De lo contrario, el primer
zombi podría pisar el puente
mientras que todavía haya gente en él.
Por último, no hay trucos aquí.
No puedes cruzar balanceándote,
usar el puente como balsa
ni hacerte amigo de los zombis.
[Para el vídeo ahora si quieres
descubrirlo por ti mismo]
[Respuesta en: 3]
[Respuesta en: 2]
[Respuesta en: 1]
Al principio podría parecer que
independientemente de lo que hagas
te faltan un minuto o dos,
pero hay una manera.
La clave es reducir el tiempo perdido
por las dos personas más lentas
haciendo que crucen juntas.
Y porque se ha de hacer un par de
viajes de regreso con la linterna,
querrás tener a la gente
más rápida haciéndolo.
Por lo tanto, tú y la
asistente de laboratorio
cruzan rápidamente con la linterna,
aunque tienes que frenar un poco
para mantener su ritmo.
Los dos están
al otro lado en dos minutos,
y tú, siendo el más rápido,
corres de vuelta con la linterna.
Han pasado solo tres minutos.
Hasta ahora, todo bien.
Ahora viene la parte difícil.
El profesor y el portero toman
la linterna y cruzan juntos.
Esto los lleva 10 minutos
ya que el portero tiene que reducir la
velocidad para acompañar al viejo profesor
quien no para de murmurar
que probablemente no debería haberles
dado visión nocturna a los zombis.
Desde el momento en que han cruzado
solo quedan cuatro minutos hasta el final,
y tú todavía estás en el lado
equivocado del puente.
Pero recuerda, la asistente de laboratorio
ha estado esperando en el otro lado,
y es la segunda más rápida del grupo.
Así que agarra la linterna del profesor
y corre de vuelta para rescatarte.
Ahora, con solo 2 minutos hasta el final,
Uds. dos emprenden la travesía.
En el momento que lleguen
al otro lado del desfiladero,
cortan las cuerdas y el puente
colapsa detrás de Uds.,
justo en el último momento.
Tal vez el verano que viene
se quedarán en la biblioteca.